I was taking a look yesterday at Donald
Trump's latest FEC filing for campaign
spending very exciting reading I'll tell
you it did I recommend you you look at
it riveting really late it's like a John
like har a novel and it's not just being
president that has been really
profitable for Donald Trump and his
family merely running for president is
funneling tons of cash into Donald
Trump's pocket and that of his family
and his business partners because Donald
Trump's campaign rents Donald Trump's
Trump Tower and other spaces regularly
Donald Trump camp Donald Trump's
campaign buys food from Donald Trump's
restaurants and from his hotels if you
look at the schedule be in Donald
Trump's recent FEC filings as I did
yesterday you will find charges
including $75,000 for renting out a
space at Trump Tower on Fifth Avenue six
thousand dollar restaurant bills you can
get a lot of turtle soup and frog legs
for six thousand dollars the Trump
campaign regularly cutting checks to
Trump Plaza Trump hotels Trump
restaurants the Trump Hotel Collection
it is very profitable for Donald Trump's
family not even to have Trump as
president which is very profitable just
for Trump to run for president
it is extremely lucrative and it is
every aspect of it that is profitable
foreign leaders come to the United
States they go to DC they stay at
Trump's DC hotel specifically to curry
favor with Donald Trump to ingratiate
themselves with Donald Trump his
campaign makes him money by renting out
his venues for events his brother
companies in which his brother holds an
ownership stake have received a ton of
government contracts since Donald Trump
became president a lot of people don't
even know Trump has a brother who's
alive a lot of people know about Trump's
brother who tragically died by suicide
they don't know Trump has a brother
still alive making tons of money off of
government contracts and what do you
think his followers would say if you
went to them and said hey uh your
donations that you made to Trump they're
going back into Trump's pocket when his
campaign pays to rent out his
taou trump tower ballroom and orders
food at trump's restaurants i know what
they would say they would say that's
great they would say every politician
does this they're all corrupt I would
rather the money go to Trump's
businesses rather than some [ __ ]
liberal restaurant at a hipster hotel or
something like that so nothing will
happen things will continue Donald Trump
will continue to line his pockets and
those of his family by virtue of being
president and there won't even be the
mere possibility of holding him
accountable so should we even do these
stories anymore that's my question to
you when we know there will be no
consequences to Donald Trump for this
the the emoluments Clause violations
that have been committed by Donald Trump
are numerous we could talk about you
know Ivanka previously sitting in for
the Secretary of State we could talk
about Jared Kushner and all of these
completely immoral connections of
unelected people who supposedly weren't
going to be involved in politics being
involved in politics at the high level
we can say had Democrats brought
impeachment along emolument lines it
would be a far more open-and-shut case
than the way that Trump's lawyers have
been able to muddle up and muddy up the
case related to Ukraine and abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress we've
had those conversations we can continue
to have them I can continue to pull FEC
reports of Trump just funneling money
right back into his own pockets through
his campaign donors but should I do it
in the sense that there aren't going to
be consequences I want to hear from you
let me know whether you think these
stories should continue to be covered on
the David Pakman show
I know that the David Pakman show
audience is full of curious and creative
people who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design book
being marketing personal productivity
doesn't even scratch the surface I
recently took a class about photography
if anybody follows me on Instagram you
know that my photography skills leave
much to be desired and it was great I
got so much out of it and hopefully you
will see the fruits of me taking that
class reflected in my Instagram pictures
sooner than later they have classes for
every skill level whether you're wanting
to get better at something you already
have experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than 10
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll